Christopher Nolan is known for his
secrecy almost as much as his filmmaking
style as such information on his next
project tenant is scarce if you're
looking for answers however you've come
to the right place this is everything we
know so far
Christopher Nolan has been pretty
consistent with his directorial schedule
since his first ever feature following
which was released in 1998 he generally
puts out a new film every two or three
years tenon however may be an exception
to this pattern with all of the release
date disruption so far in 2020 due to
theater shutdowns and other crises it's
hard to say when the flick will actually
land still we've got our fingers crossed
for some kind of summer release if
that's the case it looks like Tennant
won't have much competition at the very
least Nolan and company shouldn't have
to face off with that box office
dominating elephant in the room by which
we mean the Marvel Cinematic Universe
with the first film in the MCU base for
Black Widow now apparently arriving in
November the juggernaut franchise is
leaving the summer season clear
Christopher Nolan is pretty well known
for putting together impressive casts
with some of the biggest name actors out
there that said Tennant might surprise
you a bit with its star leading the cast
for the film is John David Washington
who has only appeared in a handful of
films at this point and though he's
clearly the lead character we don't
really know what he does in the movie
after two trailers we still don't even
know his name
it isn't like Washington is a completely
unknown or untested actor his short
career has made a big impact he's had a
recurring role as Ricky Jarrett's on
HBO's ballers and he has appeared in
films like Monsters and Men and the old
man and gun oh and he starred in a
little film called black clansmen which
got him nominated for several acting
awards including a Golden Globe and oh
yeah Fun Pack he's also Denzel
Washington's son
thanks to black Klansmen Washington Star
is burning very brightly right now if
Tennant is as big a hit as Nolan
generally puts out there Washington's
Hollywood clout will only continue to
increase actors tend to flock to Nolan's
films the interesting concepts huge
exposure and the fact that the director
generally releases pretty good films
makes him a big draw for collaborators
in addition to central lead John David
Washington Nolan staple Michael Caine
and returning thespian Kenneth Branagh
Tennant boasts some serious star power
up and down it's cast list two of Harry
Potter and the Goblet of fires Triwizard
champion sir cast in Tennant as both
Robert Pattinson and Clemont PO ser on
board
you know shooting the bullet you know
catching it
labeling them both as Harry Potter
actors is a bit reductive peach has
shown some impressive acting chops
outside of that franchise since its
wizard and vampire days Pattinson is
impressed with his work in films like
the lighthouse and good time and po se
has shown plenty of range with
television roles like the tunnel and
genius there are plenty of other big
names attached to Tennant besides these
- Elizabeth - Vicki Aaron taylor-johnson
and himesh Patel are just a few of the
others you'll easily recognize in the
cast and those are just the actors we
know about you can always count on
Christopher Nolan to work in a few
surprises fingers crossed for Killian
Murphy right when we thought it might
drop the first trailer for Tennant was
released to coincide with star wars the
rise of Skywalker it doesn't give up
much in the way of story but it does
show off a lot of mind-bending action
and features some extraordinarily
Christopher Nolan s music playing in the
background the trailer mainly focuses on
star John David Washington who was
seemingly killed and given a new lease
on life for passing a test he then is
granted some techniques that allow it to
rewind certain aspects of time or
possibly see into the future again not a
lot of the true plot is reveal we are
told however that these abilities will
apparently help him stop a global
conflict before it even begins trying to
prevent World War 3
I must say mama get in here something
less all in all it appears to be shaping
up to be another blockbuster adventure
from Christopher Nolan what I've seen
too much we'll try and keep up
all right let's move into speculation
territory
one of the biggest theories about
Tennant seems like it has to be at least
partially true due to what we know so
far this theory posits that the film is
a giant palindrome palindrome when I say
you're still talking in sentences that
are spelled the same forward and
backward a palindrome is a word or
phrase that is the same forwards and
backwards like toot racecar or that's
right Tennant Nolan is a director who
doesn't dabble much in coincidences and
as Yahoo Entertainment puts it quote the
idea of a film that works the same
forwards and backwards is so nolan asked
were surprised he hasn't done it already
a few conclusions drawn from set photos
helped prop up this theory which
suggests the film will start reversing
about halfway through with the
characters maintaining the ability to
move forward in time a few onset clips
of cars driving forward and backward
down the same street lend a bit of
credence to the theory Nolan has always
loved playing with nonlinear
storytelling and our concept of reality
so this theory does not seem like too
big a stretch considering his
filmography he really could pull his
concept off the most potentially
explosive fan Theory revolving around
Tennant is and it's actually a secret
sequel to or at least set the same
universe as Nolan's 2010 hit inception
ban theory doesn't even really do this
idea justice even major news outlets
like The Hollywood Reporter have lent
some credibility to the idea there's
quite a bit of evidence to support this
theory the taglines about a new mission
and new protagonist seemed to hint at a
world we visited before but with new
characters the international espionage
aspect of the film the mind-bending
nature of everything heck even the
rotating logo could be seen as an homage
to the top that cobb uses in Inception
to discover if he's in the real world or
not thr speculates that Tennant might
just be moderately connected to
inception and even suggest that Robert
Pattinson and Elizabeth de vikke could
be playing the grown-up versions of cops
kids
maybe that's why character names haven't
been released yet if they listed Michael
Caine as Stephen miles it would spoil
the surprise yeah Michael Caine has been
in the movie business that he knows how
to keep the hype train
moving that said the tidbit he dropped
about Tennant in a recent interview
sounds like just the type of secrecy
that director Christopher Nolan is
famous for speaking with the Hindu Kane
spoke only a bit about the upcoming film
but what he had to say about it speaks
volumes
he said Nolan is so secretive he won't
let me have the script all I had was one
day's work and it gave me my pages I did
my part and shot only with John David
Washington I haven't heard anything
since this quote gives us a few details
for one Kane's role in the film is
extremely small the only shot for a
single day secondly it tells us that
Nolan himself is probably one of the few
people who actually knows all the twists
and turns we can expect from the film as
he wanted to keep actors and frequent
collaborators in the dark hopefully
we'll get to see this thing soon and
find out what's going on for ourselves
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and TV shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]